[Music]
with black panther wakanda forever the
second movie of the series will be
released in less than a year
as of today the expected release date is
july 8th 2022 and despite there being no
trailer yet the gossip factory has been
working overtime on the plot and they
cast for months especially due to the
tragic death of lead actor chadwick
boseman on august 28 2022 how kevin
feige and ryan coogler want to pay
respects and what kind of familial faces
we will see again in the second part is
what we have summarized for you in this
video
in an effort to refresh your memory
here's a recap of the main events
leading up to black panther 2. if you
haven't seen all the current movies of
the mcu you should skip ahead now
chronologically the film will likely
take place shortly after falcon and the
winter soldier
after t'challa also known as black
panther lost his throne in a duel
against killmonger he and the dora milaj
wakanda's deadly task force managed to
take back the city
killmonger dies and king t'challa
resolves to end wakanda's isolation and
use their advanced technology in order
to aid people around the world after
that black panther joins the avengers in
the fight against thanos the first
battle on earth against the mad titan
occurs in wakanda where the hero sadly
failed to stop him as a result of thanos
snap half the life in the universe is
wiped out along with that of black
panther the blip eventually brings him
back to join the final battle against
thanos following the victory he returns
to wakanda and things become quiet
around the fatal state in africa
the next time their brave warriors make
an appearance is when they demand the
death of baron zemo the latter has
escaped from his prison in berlin thanks
to the help of sam wilson and bucky
barnes but in the end they head zemo
over to the dora milage
not much is known about the cast yet so
we can only speculate whether and to
what extent some of the roles will be
cast
what is evident is that the role of
t'challa is not going to be recast
with the tragic death of chadwick
boseman due to cancer a huge gap has
been left in the mcu that probably
nobody would be able to fill marvel
godfather kevin foggy himself addressed
the matter at an investor conference in
december 2020 saying i wanted to
acknowledge the devastating loss of a
dear friend and member of the marvel
studios family chadwick boseman was an
immensely talented actor and an
inspirational individual who affected
all of our lives professionally and
personally his portrayal of t'challa the
black panther is iconic and transcends
iteration of the character and any other
medium in marvel's past it is for that
reason that we will not recast the
character
so naturally it remains to be seen who
this spotlight will be on in the new
film
marvel did pay tribute to chadwick after
his death and changed the intro of the
first black panther movie to be a recap
of him
well at the very least the cast around
the familiar faces from wakanda is well
known of course t'challa's little sister
shuri will be back as in the first film
she is once again embodied by leticia
wright the young princess is not only a
genius in the vibranium research she is
also a strong fighter the nigeria will
also replace the role of the brave
warrior okoye after the death of bozeman
it will now probably be her main task to
protect the young princess
the agent nakia is also part of the
action as she was already a fearless
companion of black panther in the first
part lupita nyong'o is assuming her role
again we also see winston duke as a
strong warrior and baku as well as
hobbit star martin freeman as cia agent
everett k ross
the king's mother amanda played by
angela bassett will also be making a
small appearance
it is not yet known whether other
well-known black panther stars will
return we will certainly know more with
the first trailer at the latest
new to the marvel universe will be
tenokuata the mexican actor is best
known for his role as rafa carlo
quintero in the netflix series nakaz
mexico
what role he will play in wakanda
forever is still unknown so far however
insiders speculate that he could be the
new antagonist
when talking about the new villain one
particular name comes to mind first
nemer the submariner he is the king of
atlantis and not really a villain in the
comics he has also fought on this side
of the avengers the x-men and other
group of heroes however similar to the
young black panther his loyalty belongs
to his people and not to earth so if
anybody were to oppose the atlanteans he
would fight them without batting an eye
unfortunately nothing is confirmed on
this yet but this is the most persistent
rumor over the last few months also he
is already listed as nemour well at
least on wikipedia the last new cast
member is mikaela cole sadly they're not
even rumors about what kind of role she
could take on
rarely has so little been known about
the plot of an mcu film as with black
panther wakanda forever naturally this
is mainly due to the sudden death of
chadwick boseman screenwriter ryan
coogler had to completely rewrite his
existing script in less than a year
a couple of things are known though as
the name wakanda forever suggests the
film is supposed to be more about
wakanda and its people
surely this is all supposed to be
preparation for the disney plus series
of the same name after all it's a huge
country with lots of different
subcultures and tribes hence there's a
lot to tell and it's certainly not a
coincidence that the first black panther
movie won the oscar in best production
and costume design as well as the best
film music
there won't be a recasting of t'challa
nor a cgi version of bozeman the role of
black panther must be recast however and
there seems to be only one logical
solution his sister shuri in the comics
she is already his successor so why not
in the movies as well what is truly
exciting is how the possible role of
memory could be integrated as mentioned
at the beginning he is the king of
atlantis in the comics he's not too
thrilled about t'challa wanting to open
up the gates of wakanda to the world as
for himself he's trying everything he
can to keep the secrets surrounding
atlantis he may also be partly blaming
wakanda for the fact that thanos managed
to wipe out half of human life
after all if you trace the story back
wakanda was the land that lost the
vibranium to ulysses claw who sold it to
ultron which in turn created vision
and it was precisely his connection with
a mind stone that made it so difficult
to destroy in the end and well you know
how that turned out of course these are
all mere ideas but as you can see there
are plenty of possibilities to include
the king of atlantis in the plot another
possible storyline would be that of
princess zanda of narobia she's a
recurring antagonist of black panther in
the comics it would be conceivable that
she might want to use the power vacuum
after t'challa's death to gain influence
over wakanda she would definitely be a
worthy opponent for shuri or whoever
would succeed the king especially if she
manages to win influence over a
particular clans it could also be a
great way to delve into the politics and
history of wakanda
fitting for this would also be the fact
that with miguela cole an actress has
already been cast that fits into the
profile
unfortunately we can't say much more
about the events in black panther
wakanda forever yet and we don't want to
get too deep into assumptions therefore
we will have to wait a little longer
until at least the first trailer has
been released
shooting of the new film started on june
29th 2021 at grilleth studios in atlanta
according to the statement by disney
it'll take around half a year to
complete as in the first part ryan
coogler is once again the director of
the film having also written the
screenplay producer is who could be
otherwise kevin feige in addition
michael b jordan is also interested in
working on the film but in what form is
not known as of yet autumn dural takes
over from rachel morrison's
cinematographer due to delays caused by
the ongoing pandemic morrison
unfortunately had to cancel her
participation however it's not euro's
first job in the mcu she also operated
the camera on the recent loki series the
theatrical release date has been set for
july 8th 2022 in the united states
needless to say this date should be
taken with a grain of salt because as
you know release dates are subject to
change
that was our preview of black panther
wakanda forever which antagonist would
you rather see on the big screen xander
on namor all the much more important
question who would you most like to see
in a black panther suit let us know in
the comments and if you like this video
be sure to give it a thumbs up see you
next time
[Music]
you